[Music]
when you were graduating from the jew
school and by the way sorry everybody
from temple israel
uh i probably have called it
the juice
i forgot that we do that in private
[Music]
oh
yeah they probably wouldn't appreciate
me calling at the jewish school yeah oh
quick quick pin in that as well i went
to school once uh for halloween dressed
as a ninja my dad told me i was a ninja
and i threw stars of david instead
i go where you want to be and you were
like ninja i go you're not ninja you're
ninja the school called him and was like
hey that's not funny and he was like
what do you mean it's not funny of
course it's funny you were in there they
were like are you a ninja the teacher
said call me and was like i'm sorry
did you tell jacob
he was a ninja and i was like what
i go who told you that and she said well
i asked him
are you a ninja and he said no
i'm a ninja
and she said who called you that
and you said
my dad
and i was like just to be clear i didn't
call him that as a name
like to make fun of him i just wanted
him to be clear what he was yeah i just
wanted him to know his identity
they did not love that joke no i like
that joke i think that's yours
[ __ ] why not
[Music]